an outlet he the honorary award section
of the program the president of the
Academy mr. Charles Brackett
at ten o'clock last night as our bylaws
specify the Board of Governors met to
decide upon the honorary Awards these
single out achievements which do not
fall in the categories voted by our
general membership but which seemed to
the board to demand Academy recognition
to present the first of these that for
the best foreign language film of the
year apparition in America and a very
welcome one man was L Lesley Carol
the Foreign Language Film Award booth to
a remarkable Japanese film Rashomon
Japanese government's overseas office
will accept the award mr. Yashida is
coming on stage now to accept his award
for this most unusual
the Japanese reading which relates five
different interpretations of the single
story I just wished to say thank you and
I feel particularly privileged and
honored and quite excited tonight thank
you can use one brief speech for an
official of any government I would say
and about the picture well I'll go home